ça implique de fermer les écoles ce qui
a toujours été pour nous et ce qu'il
reste un ultime recours parce qu'on sait
le coût éducatif le couches sociales
pour un terme à la violence pour
certains enfants de la fermeture des
écoles si votre question est de savoir
si hier en conseil qu'en défense pas on
a abordé les mesures on a décidé
d'avancer les vacances la réponse est
non alors la réponse est non deux
ministres tapie dont une roselyne
bachelot en oxygénation trois nouveaux
départements en confinement dans les
hauts de france des hospitalisations
dépasser les niveaux atteints lors des
deux première vague de l'épidémie ce qui
a imposé une poursuite des transferts de
patients 90% des réalisations sont
occupés sophie de menthon il faut quand
même faire quelque chose à côté de la
question est bien posée nous j'ai
l'impression que la crise est gérée en
dépit du bon sens quand je dis cette
phrase c'est vraiment ça je ne comprends
pas la façon dont se gérer je vais pas
accuser le gouvernement c'est
horriblement difficile ils ont raison de
vouloir préserver
ils ont eu raison de préserver
l'éducation des enfants et l'école ça a
des incidences directes d'ailleurs sur
les entreprises
il semble quand même que les enfants ne
soient pas contagieux mais je suis
sidéré parce que le ministre de
l'éducation par exemple il a qu'à
simplement regarder ce qu'on fait en
angleterre qui fait pareil parce que là
et nous a menti quand même je suis
désolé mais il nous a menti soit disant
les élèves sont testés les tests
salivaires que nous fournissons nos
entreprises d'ailleurs et que nous
mettons en place dans les écoles parce
que les écoles n'ont pas les moyens de
le faire donc c'est des boîtes privées
qui vont faire ça avec des aberrations
le test salivaire doit être dépouillé
dans un laboratoire lobby des
laboratoires alors que c'est comateuse
de grossesse pourrait se faire très
rapidement
bon ils sont pas testés ou très peu
ensuite ils sont testés en angleterre
carrément tous les deux trois jours avec
des petits tests qui sont immédiatement
analysable sur place sans problème les
parents reçoivent le même test que les
enfants qu'ils s'administrent eux-mêmes
viriat on était capable de mener quelque
chose à bien avec simplicité rigueur et
professionnalisme
donc nos enfants ne sont pas testés ils
sont pas ils sont peut-être un peu
contagieux mais ne sont pas malades ce
qui est déjà ça en tout cas certainement
pas les petits c'est à paris qui a été
fait de laisser les écoles ouvertes et
je dois dire que c'est très dangereux
pour le pays de fermer les écoles c'est
dangereux pour les enfants c'est
dangereux pour les parents c'est
dangereux pour les entreprises
est ce que c'est vraiment quelque chose
qui est nécessaire pour éradiquer le
virus je ne suis pas du tout certaine je
pense que la seule chose à faire c'est
la vaccination et que là encore on est
dans des on nous explique toute la
journée les vaccinodromes où on va
vacciner etc mais sans parler du vote
les vaccins or aujourd'hui tout le monde
peut vacciner les pharmaciens dit madame
je vous préviens dès que j'ai une dose
les
tout le monde peut vacciner il ya les
médecins tout le monde s'y met les
infirmières c'est pas un problème les
mairies qui sont particulièrement
efficaces
alors bon vaccinodromes pourquoi pas
sans vaccin donc ça c'est un autre
problème c'est pas non plus on va rester
on pourrait les laisser ouverte si on
prenait exemple sur les anglais
si on prenait exemple sur les anglais
ceci dit les angles ils ont laissé calme
et écoles fermées pendant 26 semaines
s'est ouverte
elles sont de nouveau ouvertes c'est
vrai richard tous les responsables
d'établissements le dise on n'a pas
encore aujourd'hui enfin pas tous enfin
ce que de nombreux en tous les cas ce
que j'ai avec qui j'ai eu l'occasion de
discuter me disent tous la même chose on
n'a pas encore rattrapé les dégâts
causés par l'enseignement à distance
lors de la première vague les jeunes
certains ont décroché d'autres sont
déboussolés peut-être pas arrêter les
frais là éviter quand même de suivre
peut-être trop les médecins et les
docteurs cassandre et si on vacciner les
propres déjà alors peut-être qu'on peut
prendre là la formulation à l'envers on
peut se dire qu'il vaut mieux
effectivement laissé le plus longtemps
possible des écoles ouvertes pour les
réseaux des raisons qu'on a connus au
premier confinement des dégâts sur la
scolarisation des dégâts pour les
décrocheurs des complexités vraiment
certaine pour les familles notamment
celles qui vivent dans des petits
appartements pour tous ceux qui
n'avaient pas les moyens d'accompagner
non plus leurs enfants à suivre les
enseignements tout ça on a bien vu les
dégâts et donc pour cette raison là on
va laisser les écoles ouvertes et puis
pour la vie économique qui implique
quand même que les parents puissent
aller travailler et ne pas être à la
maison en train de garder dans tout ça
c'est vraiment important mais ça veut
dire qu'à côté on est sûr d'avoir des
mesures qui sont adaptées en fonction de
l'épidémie
or qu'est ce qu'on constate c'est que
castex est venu le premier ministre nous
raconter ce qu'ils allaient prendre
comme mesure d'ailleurs personne n'a à
peu près rien compris à la différence
entre ce qui avait la veille et le
surlendemain
mais peu importe mais par rapport aux
écoles quelle augmentation du protocole
quel niveau renforcé de protocole
aucun on a gardé le même protocole alors
que dans 16 départements l'épidémie
flambe donc il est normal que l'épreuve
s'interrogeait normal que l'état
on s'interroge si l'épidémie circulent
davantage dans la ville il est normal
que l'école se protège des parents les
parents et les profs c'est pas forcément
ils n'ont pas forcément les mêmes soucis
gens peut-être mais ils ont aussi lancé
à l'hiver il certains syndicats de profs
eux ont préféré vont fermer les classes
et oracle et les associations de parents
d'élèves préférais quand on laisse les
écoles ouvertes soul est d'abord c'est
pas aussi caricatural comme ça j'ai pas
d'abord n'en veut enfin c'est quand même
il ya beaucoup sa riche non mais c'est
pas aussi caricatural n'y a pas que des
syndicats d'enseignants qui aujourd'hui
s'interrogent sur la mise en place des
protocoles je vous prends des exemples
très simple quand vous avez un prof qui
est absent il ya une solution
soit vous remplacer les profs soit vous
ne le remplace et pas auquel cas ça veut
dire que les enfants sont répartis dans
d'autres classes ça veut dire que vous
augmenter le nombre d'élèves par classe
et que vous emportez les brassages c'est
très bête mais c'est ce qu'on veut
casser donc c'est idiot donc remplaçons
les profs qui sont absents quand vous
avez aujourd'hui des phénomènes à la
cantine il ya un truc très bête qui est
de savoir et le capteur de co2 parce que
ça fait partie en gros des éléments qui
vont permettre de savoir si on est ou
pas dans une zone qui peut devenir à
risque en matière de
on en a pas dans les écoles quand un
moment donné vous dites que vous allez
reprendre certaines activités notamment
sportives etc
sur quelle base de protocole alors que
quelques jours avant on vous dit qu'on
ne pouvait pas l'épidémie augmenter tout
d'un coup vous pouvez tout ça n'est pas
nécessairement compréhensible en tant
que tel donc c'est pas l'idée de moi
encore une fois je ne suis pas pour la
fermeture des écoles pour les raisons
que j'ai indiqué aux débats mais je suis
pour qu'il y ait un protocole adapté et
je rejoins sophie en plus du protocole
il a l'idée de la vaccination
il faut vacciner les profs mais moi je
suis pour qu'on va 6 et aussi ceux qui
sont les personnels éducatifs idrees à
100 aujourd'hui
sailly dans certaines écoles les
assistantes maternelles elles sont
présentes et qu'est ce qu'elles font
elles font la classe à la place du prof
qui est absent parce qu'il n'est pas
remplacé donc dire qu'on va vacciner
aussi ce personnel là ne me paraît pas
être aujourd'hui incongru on veut
maintenir les écoles ouvertes
donnons nous les moyens avec un
protocole adapté et la vaccination
et là on pourra maintenir les écoles je
verrai aujourd'hui quelque chose là
dessus c'est que il ya une association
une
ces familles qui a amis on a tous
regardé ce repreneur pour la république
et aux chambres un entrepreneur pour la
république
là c'est des entrepreneurs qui ont des
solutions contre locaux vides qui
mettent leurs solutions vous pouvez pas
vous imaginer ce qu'il y a il ya des
pâtures virucide il ya des détecteurs
effectivement dans l'air de virus il ya
des des trucs pour le maintien la
distanciation il ya tout ce qu'on veut
l'état un mépris pour toute solution
d'abord qui vient du privé et pour toute
solution
comment dire qu'on cren entrepreneuriale
de bon sens il ya peut-être que oui ce
que dit sofia campe sans doute aussi les
lourdeurs administratives
sûrement même néanmoins néanmoins on est
un an après le premier
mahmoud a dit elle mammouth de
l'éducation nationale ouais mais je
pense que le prendre comme ça c'est
aussi nier une autre chose c'est que
depuis le début on a refusé en france
d'avoir le débat sur confiné ou pas
confiné fin de fermer ou pas fermer les
écoles on a refusé le débat
les tests salivaires rigueur de l'avant
dernière vague non elles ont été fermés
pour la première vague est depuis qu'est
ce qu'on fait on dit on n'y va pas et on
n'a pas le débat le ministre ne veut pas
assez chômeuse gones à chaque fois très
bien mais show must go on met les moyens
à côté aujourd'hui on les a pas les
tests salivaires en effet depuis quand à
grande échelle non les faits pour les
années shell d'une part et d'autre part
depuis quand les faits trois semaines
d'accord donc c'est ça en fait on n'a
pas fait la vérité sur ce truc là on a
mis la question sous le tapis
aujourd'hui elle est sur la table et on
se la pose
un an après l'angleterre assez posé
cette question bien avant l'angle
l'allemagne se déposer avant l'italie
aussi si ces pays sont arrivés à fermer
leur école moi je dis que ce n'est pas
simplement de gaieté de coeur
c'est une décision qui a été lourde à
prendre évitons de prendre très au
sérieux comme ces pays là j'ai su gérer
c'est garry beitel autres on peut pas
assez déterminé parce que vous l'avez
dit qui décide
est ce que le patron excusez-moi sadr
est le patron d'une école j'emploie
volontairement le mot c'est lui qui
devrait exiger des sablons vous savez
qu'au début on naît pas de savon pour se
laver les mains
mais je vais le gamin de savon dans les
écoles pour se laver les mains des gens
à s'évader
il y avait des pins qui souillent
évaluer le bac était absolument peu plus
précis
non mais une horreur mais je suis désolé
il n'y a pas trop d'une école qu'elles
soient privées ou publiques et puis si
ya pas de savon on dit aux parents à
porter des savons et puis il faut des
efforts parce qu on est tous concerné
par ça donc il n'y a qu'elle est le
patron d'école directeur d'école qui
veut dire ok maintenant tous vaccinés
net ou tout personnel éducatif doit être
vacciné dans mon établissement
à ma droite klaxons décidé on nous a
demandé 16 départements vous dis oui on
commence dans les fesses des parties ce
que vous dit inde aux internautes que
chalut parce que c'est le premier à
s'être admis avoir salué sur le chat du
figaro il se fait appeler chardon bleu
bon soin et vous dites est le problème
sur le 1,5 c'est qu'il n'y a pas assez
de 2 euros alors à quoi ça sert d'avoir
simplement moi je veux bien qu'on parle
de ça mais en réalité aujourd'hui
si on prend sur kobe de trekkeurs là on
a une estimation qui est même passée les
doses réceptionné en france et 10838801
administrer ses 9 millions oui donc ça
veut dire qu'il ya un million de doses
ya un million et demi de dos et qui dit
aujourd'hui mais rennes qui aujourd'hui
très luiz est ce que vous avez dit sur
un plateau josé entendu c'est un million
et demi dose qui à un moment donné ne
sont pas administrés alors que nous les
avons donc on a un problème de
logistique depuis le début sur la
vaccination
on a des doses qui aujourd'hui ne
devrait pas être dans les frigos elles
devraient être injectés
on devrait en flux tendu c'est du zéro
frigo qu'on devrait voir ce que c'est la
pac si on quand on dit qu'on ne peut pas
quand il ya un million et demi de doses
qui ne sont pas aujourd'hui utilisés ben
on peut faire des choses avec un million
et demi dose et si on prend les 16
départements qui sont aujourd'hui avec
des restrictions renforcées commençons
par là commençons la vaccination des
profs et des personnels éducatifs et
c'est à ce à ce tarif là qu'on réussira
à maintenir les écoles ouvertes puisque
on le veut
puissent les à merci d'avoir répondu à
chardons bleus
je salue également antoine sur twitter
qui nous dit une fermeture des écoles
aggravera encore plus le niveau de
l'instruction mais avancé les vacances
permettrait de limiter les
contaminations sophie alors ça c'est des
moyens comme toujours tous les jours
quelque chose de nouveau
ah bon en avant ces vacances de pâques
alors je vous dis quand même au passage
qu'il ya quand même quelques personnes
qui travaillent sur la question qu'on
peut se lasser du figaro et aux
internautes du figaro qui pour l'instant
ne sont pas emballés on va le voir par
cette hypothèse alors je vais pas me
regarder les conséquences parce qu'après
tout alors il ça veut dire qu'elle
commencerait en fait appris le week-end
de pâques bon il ya quand même des gens
qui ont posé des vacances les
entreprises pour garder leurs enfants
s'ils partent pas parce qu'en principe
on ne sort pas des départements qui sont
confinés donc sa déstabilisation totale
de la boîte ah bon non mais là il faut
que je change mes vacances etc
vous avez même y compris dans les écoles
ça c'est compliqué qu'est ce qui va se
passer qu'est-ce que ça va changer ça
veut dire en fait qu'on en gros c'est
comme si on fermer l'école quinze jours
ils sont en train de se dire on ferme
pas l'école mais si on met les vacances
avant la ferme quinze jours est-ce que
fermer une école qu un jour mettre les
enfants en vacances à une véritable
incidence la propagation du virus je ne
sais pas c'est vraiment la question mais
qui pose une autre question qui est la
nature des mesures qui ont été prises
par le premier ministre d'accord mais
même si les meuse les mesures énorme
vous suivre sont mauvaises richard
maintenant est ce qu'est ce qu'on fait
est ce qu'on avance par exemple les
vacances de pâques une quinzaine de
jours et aucun horizon veille de
franchement enfin moi je suis pas
épidémiologistes mais tous les
épidémiologistes vous diront que quinze
jours à syfy par absolument pas
l'inversé de courbes d'accord
aujourd'hui le problème c'est que on
ajoute une mesure à des mesures
générales qui aujourd'hui ont quoi comme
restrictions l'adie fait la grande
différence entre ce qu'ils avaient avant
est ce qu'il ya aujourd'hui c'est qu'on
est passé 18 à 19 heures et qu'on a pu
les voyages interrégionaux et avec ça on
doit n'ont pas freiné une courbe
on doit la casse et l'inversé on est à
quasiment trente mille cas positifs
uniquement de ceux qui se sont fait
tester ça veut pas dire que cela n'a pas
davantage puisque tout le monde ne se
fait pas à tester donc ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire
on est aujourd'hui sur des logiques qui
sont un peu plus enflammés que ce que
nous dit le premier quelque chose de
positif c'est que mme enfin l'institut
pasteur pour lesquelles j'ai pas une
admiration folle a découvert que au
plein air on avait très peu de chances
de se contaminer sauf si évidemment il
ya dix môme qui sont là sur une pelouse
en lacets c'est pas terrible mais
maintenant c'est 6 dehors on va avoir
des amendes assez bon dès qu'il ya des
amendes le virus va reculer
donc on a il a découvert et puis il ya
un changement d'heure ils sont du
changement d'heure c'est embêtant parce
que vraiment ils vont être trop tôt donc
c'est pas idiot d'être dehors c'est
intelligent et le que l'état publie les
directives qui permettent aux
enseignants de faire des cours dehors
des classes vertes c'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui je crois
ils ont froid les directives parce que
c'est comme ça veut dire je suis désolé
je suis professeur j'ai le droit d'aller
dans la cour faire mon cours et le
directeur décide
nous n'avons personne qui décide un jour
il y aura un peu plus d'autonomie dans
les établissements on en reparlera mais
aujourd'hui on parle des rallys ne verra
le jour
oh non pas que le libéralisme a besoin
de ça la priorité est l'économie c'est
un beau débat je louperai que parce
qu'on est ce qu'on les mille et un petit
peu plus vaste celui de savoir s'il faut
fermer là oui ça l'est les écoles un
petit peu plus tôt la priorité en tous
les cas nous dit cet internaute et
l'économie or il faut que les écoles
soit ouverte pour que les actifs
puissent travailler
les enseignants ont déjà assez de
vacances je pense que cette formule
réagir nos invités
on vient d'entendre la règle sophie
j'attends celle de richard sur le fait
que les enseignants aient trop de
vacances c'était le problème du moment
franchement je craignais qu'on en parle
mais je crois qu'on n'en est pas
vraiment à ce niveau là bas dit qu'on
était plus de vacances on a dit que les
avances y est ce que vous pensez que
c'est pas qu'on va les décalés on va
aller les quinze jours qu'on mettra
plutôt on va les rattraper
à la date où il fait prévu initialement
les vacances de printemps vont les
choses moi je suis pour qu'on ait un
dialogue social intelligent avec les
organisations syndicales
si on prend 15 exil à z oui c'est de
poser dialogue social à tgc possible
accord faut juste prendre aussi des fois
les syndicats pour ce qu'ils sont et non
pas pour ce qu'ils ne sont pas ceux que
le ministre a peut-être eu tendance à
faire un peu trop par moments
en l'occurrence sur une crise il faut y
aller ensemble et il faut pas y aller
mollo d'accord et pour le coup moi je ne
suis pas contre le fait qu'on
réfléchisse à ce qu'on fait au mois de
juillet et ce qu'on prolonge pas de 15
jours est-ce qu'on prolonge pas d'un peu
plus mais en faisant vraiment de l'école
et pas des espèces de vacances apprenant
dollarisation des vacances qui sont un
truc un peu idiot mais prolonge où il y
aura une grève des profs mais peut-être
pas si on en parle maintenant avec eux
je ne pense je ne suis pas sûr et je
salue également nicole qui viennent nous
rejoindre et également sur le chat du
figaro est également kriss kross qui est
absolument contre tout contre l'idée de
fermer les écoles en termine avec jah
jah sur youtube qui nous dit il faut
rester chez soi en 2020 et en 2021 il
faut se confiner dehors faut pas se
mettre de masques en 2020 et en 2021
faut porter un masque dehors c'est
insupportable c'est la question en tous
les cas quand vous posez sur twitter la
clape à sur twitter également sur
twitter mais d'abord et avant tout sur
le site du figaro faut-il avancer le
début des vacances de pâques pour
freiner l'épidémie de kovy de 10,9
hélas pour l'instant quand on a
justement fait l'état des lieux au
compteur vous voyez que c'est un non
franc et massif pour reprendre la
formule du regretté général de gaulle la
deuxième question qu'on se pose cette
fois ci sur twitter c'est oui j'avais
envie de
de plaire la communauté gaulliste ce
soit la deuxième question la chaussée il
y aura le y aura les tours font napoléon
également des communautés fortes et
structurées sur sur le web la deuxième
question qu'on se pose cette fois ci sur
twitter c'est la nouvelle mosquée de
strasbourg doit-elle bénéficier de
financements publics on précise que
c'est la plus grande d'europe et la
mairie de strasbourg a voté lundi une
subvention de deux millions et demi
d'euros à l'association d'obédience turc
milligray russe alors mis les goristes
une association qui a été fondée par
quelqu'un que les plus de moins de 20
ans ne peuvent pas connaître
qu'ils s'appellent necmettin erbakan qui
a été premier ministre turc à la fin des
années 90 avant d'être renversé par les
militaires
et c'est également le mentor d'erdogan
alors quand il a créé l'association
cette fois ci dans la fin des années 60
c'était pour regrouper la diaspora
turque et surtout la soustraire au
maximum à la vision laïque du fondateur
de la turquie moderne
kemal atatürk l'association aujourd'hui
gère 70 lieux de culte elle a refusé de
signer la charte pour l'islam de france
une charte qui marque la différence
entre la religion et la politique et la
prééminence des lois françaises
d'où cette réaction de gérald darmanin
ce matin à l'encontre justement de cette
délibération et de cette subvention
votée donc par le conseil municipal de
strasbourg
nous avons vu cette délibération votée
par le conseil municipal de strasbourg
et j'ai eu l'occasion de dire à même la
maire de strasbourg la fête l'avait dit
avant moi et je me suis cru et
publiquement que nous ne trouvions pas
ça pour le moins amicales avec les
intérêts français pour ne pas dire plus
pourquoi parce que cette fédération que
vous évoquez pro turquie n'a pas voulu
signer la charte des valeurs de la
république et il ya particulièrement à
strasbourg des tentatives d'ingérences
extrêmement fortes sur dans notre pays
de la part notamment de la turquie et
nous considérons
que n aurait pas dû cette connectivité
financer une ingérence étrangère sur
notre site et voici la réponse de la
maire europe ecologie les verts 2
strasbourg jeanne bar saignant gérald
darmanin pose un certain nombre de
questions est ce que du coup ça signifie
qu'ils s'opposent qui remet en cause le
droit local et et le concordat
dans ce cas là je pense qu'il faut le
dire clairement c'est une manière de
dire que le gouvernement souhaite mettre
en cause le concordat et les règles en
vigueur dans notre dans notre région et
dans ce cas là je pense qu'il faut il
faut le dire clairement
et si par contre il a des doutes ou des
alertes paris particulière concernant le
respect des valeurs de la république
c'est aussi à lui de le dire alors
richard houis que je veux pas vous
mettre mal avec vos alliés écolos
surtout dans deuxième à 12e
arrondissement mais j'ai vu que olivier
faure dont vous êtes proche et qui
s'exprime dans les prochaines heures
dans le figaro a condamné et c2c l'aide
à reese et de l'unef et a condamné sa
dérive islamo-gauchiste avec des mots
clairs ferme
vous approuvez dans ces conditions la
subvention de la mairie de strasbourg
alors je met pas sur le même plan le
débat sur l'islam au 6 mai ce qui se
passe avec le financement enfin cette
délibération adoptée par le conseil
municipal de strasbourg
pour moi il ya deux chauffards ya il ya
trois hommes étaient pas son nom parce
qu'on n'est pas là sur je pense une
dérive islamo-gauchiste telle qu'elle a
été dénoncée chez un syndicat étudiant
pour des dérives qui sont liées à la
fois à des propos à des attitudes à des
manières d'organiser la vie de ce
syndicat qui se sépare un petit peu de
ces valeurs universelles et de son
message émancipateur et puis là on est
sur autre chose il ya un conseil
municipal qui délibère dans un cadre un
peu particulier c'est le premier sujet
c'est l'existence du concordat le
concordat permet des choses à certains
départements en france qui ne permet pas
aux autres qui sont sous un autre signé
sur celui des lois de la république et
donc le rapport à la laïcité est un
petit peu différent dans certains
départements et puis dans le reste de la
france je pense que franchement c'est un
sujet il faudra y revenir moi je suis
pour qu'il y est
mission parlementaire réfléchit à la
mise en place d'un d'une réflexion sur
la manière dont on gère demain le
concordat c'est mon premier point au
deuxième
c'est parce que justement c'est il ya
matière à débat par rapport à ça est ce
que l'on va parler clair mais paraît
clair est-ce que vous êtes comme jean
luc mélenchon favorable à la suppression
du concorde je vous ai dit ce que la ce
à quoi j'étais favorable
je suis favorable à ce qui est une
mission qui permet de déterminer que
cette mission mais écoutez vous trouvez
pas que c'est un peu paradoxal parce que
ce qui existe là ça existe parce qu'on
est sous le régime du concordat ça
n'existerait absolument pas dans une
autre municipalité
aujourd'hui on a la même chose à paris
les affaires sont réglés et anne hidalgo
je crois d'ailleurs s'est exprimé chez
nos confrères dans une radio matinale en
disant qu' elle ne l'aurait pas fait
parce qu'il faut y aller sur ces genres
de libération avec beaucoup de prudence
le cadre du concordat a permis qu'il y
ait quelque chose qui rend moi je pense
que c'est un vrai sujet qu'il faut
revenir sur des principes et voir
comment je suis pour qu'il y ait cette
mission hautement je voudrais saluer la
façon dont vous avez réussi à éviter le
sujet au sens bien que vous êtes contre
mais c'était remarquable parce que vous
êtes appuyé sur des bases culturelles et
si on prend vous n'avez pas laisser
finir mais vous devez absolument plus
important qu'il ne veut plus jamais
condom démission 1 parce que c'est
insupportable mais non mais c'est vrai
on aurait dû y penser avant d'abord et
là on est devant à fait mais la pensée
avant c'est pas la première fois que je
le demande le nom met d'accord mais ça
vous aussi messieurs
mais ce que je veux dire c'est que c'est
très simple là ils n'ont pas signé la
charte de la laïcité c'est pas sur la
tempe en arizona où il menaçait mais
outre aux soins ce mais l'autre point
c'est vrai si mamie ne m'interdis des
biens qui tous deux suivent à deux
points à la laïcité tâches et les
assurer sa balade homme attendait mais
on a fait la même question c'est est-ce
que vous êtes favorables comme le
demande jean luc mélenchon à la
suppression du concordat en alsace
moselle à je me sens juste 113
[Musique]
je ne sais pas moi je vous repose la
question c'est quand même assez frappant
pour le sud est de la suite on va être
d'accord
cette norme est juste sur ces
définitions de concret sauf que je ne
serai pas en avant de préparer cette
émission j'ai découvert que le concordat
de 1902 mais qui est en vigueur en
alsace-moselle concerne quatre cultes le
catholicisme et les deux protestantisme
historique du terrien est calviniste le
judaïsme mais pas l'islam et comme vous
avez justement pour ces combines
subventions et comme vous avez été
particulièrement férus dans vos études
vous avez bien noté qu'en 1999 une
motion avait été passé au conseil rural
de strasbourg qui permettait que de
relater que l'on traite aussi le culte
musulman sur le même titre que ces
religions qui existaient à l'époque du
concordat alors qu' il n'y avait pas
forcément à la même valeur légale
vous avez bien vu quand même que on est
là dans un cadre qui suit la
délibération d'un conseil municipal qui
fait qu'ils s'appuient sur ce on va
s'appliquer ici n'est pas les valeurs de
république
c'est au dessus ou alors c'est mon
deuxième point aux riches heures de
higuain
c'est mon deuxième point et j'y arrive
et là dessus on aura je pense alors fait
mon deuxième point est le suivant
l'association qui s'est vu octroyer la
subvention ce pas la mosquée qu'à la
subvention celle associée à
l'association ela c'est ce que note
cette association russell fait
visiblement de la part de l'état l'objet
d'une surveillance pour -2 fait d'abord
elle n'a pas signé la charte des
principes de la laïcité
gérald darmanin l'a répété dans les
failles non et la convention d'istanbul
mais qui conserve le droit des femmes et
pour lequel cette association
visiblement n'est pas férue et ne l'a
pas adapté pour ces deux raisons la
réalise pour ces deux raisons là
aujourd'hui alors qu'on a un débat sur
le séparatisme alors qu'on a un débat
sur la laïcité alors qu'on a un débat
sur le respect des valeurs de la
république
ça aurait dû mettre la puce à l'oreille
de la municipalité
si elle a bien les informations et c'est
mon troisième point je je je conteste le
fait qu'il puisse y avoir dans ses
affaires un fonctionnement qui met d'un
côté la mairie et l'autre côté l'état je
pense que les deux doigts
marcher ensemble les informations
doivent se passer et qu'il est
impossible on est un tapis vert après
une délibération
si quelqu'un n'a pas donné les
informations alain pivert
en gros on peut pas avoir le débat qu'on
aurait ce débat ne devrait pas avoir
lieu entre l'état et la ville soit il ya
eu des discussions effectivement saisi
on est capable de le on est capable de
le prouver
moi j'entends ce que dit la presse à
interdire en ce que dit la préfète de
strasbourg ce que dit après fait pas de
strasbourg mme la préfète votre
département c'est nous avons alerté sur
le sujet ce que dit la la maire de
strasbourg dans l'extrait que vous avez
donnée n'est pas exactement la même
chose
moi ce que je la ressentais parole oui
eh ben on devrait pas avoir ça sur un
sujet comme celui là il faudrait que les
deux ce soit quand même entendu et
discuter avant et que la faire de ce
côté là soient claires et s'il ya un
problème
elle va en gros on l'assument et on le
sait mais là en l'occurrence on ne sait
pas qui a dit oui qu'il ya dix ans
l'état et les villes doivent marcher
ensemble sur ce type de délibération
c'est impossible d'y aller chacun de son
côté
et d'ailleurs on prend tous des coups
sûrs des débats on devrait pas en avoir
si cette association ne respectent pas
les principes et les valeurs de la
république et la convention d'istanbul
ça donnait assez d'éléments pour ne pas
forcément aller vers cette subvention
je crois que c'est aussi dans les propos
d'olivier fort puisque vous avez cités
selon l'unef mais je crois que sur la
partie qui concerne strasbourg et qui
sera bientôt dévoilée je crois qu'il a
aussi un propos qui est assez claire
donc soyons clairs sur les choses
bon alors moi je voudrais être encore
plus clair à partir du moment où le ou
la laïcité la convention d'istanbul
n'ont pas été signés c'est niet
ce n'est même pas la peine c'est ce que
je suis d'accord vous avez exactement
visible peut dire d'accord je vais plus
directement ce que je veux dire c'est
que la question doit pas se poser et le
ministre de l'intérieur vous l'avez dit
a directement aussi a le droit de dire
non c'est tout alors en plus il faut
savoir que cit assez violent convient
quand même quelque chose de difficile
aujourd'hui que ya des mosquées qui sont
des véritables arsenaux qu'il ya des
vrais dangers
on se doute à oui il ya des vrais
dangers il ya des mosquées ou où tous
les toutous ce qui est anti anti
français ou anti notre culture contre
notre culture se décide
oui c'est vraiment des arsenaux sens
symbolique du terme
ouais ouais ouais il y en a dans
lesquelles ça se passe
oui ailleurs mais il ya effectivement le
cas s'il y est de confession musulmane à
mes vies dame en un an mais qu'on fasse
il ya les bons musulmans et l'islam de
france on y lit à deux interventions que
vincent le noble réseaux sociaux nous
fait parvenir donc celle d'alexandre sur
youtube et qui nous dit on doit
renforcer les liens entre la communauté
musulmane et l'état si les mosquées sont
dépendantes des financements turcs ou
saoudiens c'est une ingérence de plus
qui fragilise l'union en france en tous
les cas vous avez soulevé richard la
question de la problème de la
problématique de l'ingérence étrangère
notamment à travers ça effectivement pas
un point qu'on atteint est-ce que c'est
pas justement là l'un des problèmes
finalement l'intervention de l'état est
ce qu'elle ne doit pas justement se
faire sur cette base là est ce que bon
il ya des questions religieuses mais il
ya également les questions politiques
qui sont qui sont posées derrière oui il
ya les vins jeanjean moi j'entends le 12
janvier la grande mosquée d'europe avec
fronde souffle qui en plus ressemble
étrangement à celle à la basilique
sainte sophie qui a été remise hambourg
et qualifier là-bas lacrymogènes sur un
plat et comment sur la plan
architectural
non mais peut-être parce qu'un autre
débat mais en tous les cas c'est pas et
c'est pas non c'est pas une petite salle
de prière c'est quand même c'est un
symbole fort
oui mais encore une fois ces lieux peut
être dans un lieu où il ya eu des
affrontements en plus de conflits
importé entre turcs et kurdes
non mais je pense que c'est je pense que
c'est là où moi je le reprends ma
dernière proposition qui est de dire on
ne peut pas avoir sur ces affaires
l'état qui marche d'un côté la ville
alors qu'est ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui
concrètement
moi je suis pour qu'ils aient une
suspension de cette délibération parce
que je considère que techniquement c'est
possible mais je ne sais pas mais je
suis prêt est ce que oui parce que je
pense que le préfet a probablement des
moyens d'intervenir mais si la préfète
dont le communiqué de presse évoque des
points qui sont importants quand même
concernant
cette association si ce que dit gérald à
malin et on n'a aucun moyen de contester
ni aucune raison de contester ce qu'il
ce qu'il dit qu'elle n'a pas signé
effectivement la charte des principes si
par ailleurs avec cette association on a
un sujet parce que je crois que la
préfète évoque dans son communiqué que
c'est une association qui est plutôt lié
aux frères musulmans
bref ça fait un faisceau quand même d'un
disque qui montre que on a peut-être
intérêt à regarder cette délibération en
revanche moi je ne fais pas l'amalgamé
en disant il est aussi certain que nous
avons des concitoyennes concitoyens de
confession musulmane qui ont aussi le
droit d'exercer leur culte et que pour
la plupart d'entre l'immense majorité
d'entre eux ne m'avait jamais illégaux
voilà il mais il faut le préciser dans
l'université
donc qu'est ce qu'on fait c'est non pour
cette financement sinon voilà donc voilà
pris fin et mêlant suspense sur le nom
pour le financement à cette association
d'accord la nouvelle mosquée de
strasbourg doit-elle bénéficier de
financements publics c'est la question
qu'on vous posez sur twitter et vous
êtes une large majorité à répondre non
86% un petit peu plus que au début de
l'émission mais moi que ce les réponses
sur le site du figaro hier merci
beaucoup de nous avoir suivis désolé
pour les problèmes qu'il ya eu au début
d'émission donc je vous redis ce que je
vous n'êtes peut-être pas entendu en
début d'émission mais qu on est ravi de
vous retrouver qu'on est désolé de
l'absence momentanément momentanée de
point de vue en début de semaine dus à
présent au fait qu' on avait on était
moins nombreux à pouvoir produire cette
émission en raison de nombreux cas
contacts mais les cas contacts sont
heureusement négatif et on est heureux
de les retrouver et on les saluer en
remercie tout le travail qui a été fait
depuis notamment sous l'égide de maxime
punis
le responsable de la programmation de
figaro live voilà vous saurez tout merci
de nous avoir suivis et dans quelques
instants vous allez pouvoir suivre
l'intervention d'olivier véran survient
sur les questions de confinement de
corner virus de freinage tout ça est à
retrouver sur figaro live à vous restez
avec nous restez sur le site du
figaro.fr vous attendez pas désolé
vendredi
[Musique]